you will have a million ideas you will
think all of these ideas
would be really fun businesses to run
you'll picture yourself running them
you'll think this is definitely the
thing i want to work on for the next 10
or 20 years
and then you will wake up one morning
realizing that like you fell asleep
thinking about one idea you woke up
thinking about one idea you dreamed
about that idea you got in the shower
and you thought about that idea like you
will reach obsession
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leomi tech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
this episode really is all about
entrepreneurial spirit
and weight management meet isabel canyon
founder and ceo of calibrate prior to
calibrate she led the successful
business operations growth and strategic
partnerships and communications teams at
capsule
a technology business that has raised
270 million dollars to rebuild the
pharmacy from the inside out
before capsule isabel worked at beloved
consumer brands in london and new york
and was selected to the forbes 30 under
30 retail and e-commerce list
in 2015. she began her career as an
investment banker in hong kong
and graduated from the university of
pennsylvania is the bell canyon welcome
to 20 minute leaders thank you so much
for joining me i know how terribly busy
you are thank you
thank you michael excited to be here i
am
always fascinated to talk about the
journeys of people
following their intrinsic motivations
and one of the things that i'm seeing in
your journey all the way from upenn
i believe in east asian studies uh
transitioning to
more to the transitioning more to
medicine
and health whether whether it may be
today at calibrate
or previously as an entrepreneur in
residence
at uh redesigned health or capsule
before
what is it about health that draws you
so much
as a leader as an entrepreneur what is
it
it's one of those things that probably
doesn't make a whole lot of sense at the
time but makes a ton of sense in
retrospect and so
um i grew up i spent a lot of time
studying abroad i spent a lot of time
trying to see the world traveling
um i fell in love with chinese culture
and language i majored in it
in college i spent the early part of my
career living and working in hong kong
in the early 2000s
um the economy was completely
transforming it was changing super
quickly
a recruiter called me and said if you
like working in hong kong you will
really like working in startups
and they were right and i went and i
took my first job at a startup and i had
a variety of different jobs and
different startup roles on the marketing
side on the general manager side
and then broke my back in pelvis skiing
and it was my first
real interaction with the health care
system and i was fundamentally from that
moment
obsessed um and everything about it
didn't make sense to me i thought if you
built this from scratch around the
consumer you would build something
totally different than what we have
and the quality of care in the us is so
incredible
but the delivery of that care is so
archaic
and how do we fix that and i became
totally obsessed with the idea that
healthcare was one big retail business
that should be an e-commerce business
okay so i i have to delay on on the
section because because it seems that
you know the the something
that triggered your understanding of the
of the system and you
you you got a lens into a complicated
system that that i
you know fortunately few people get to
experience truly and and it made you up
it sounds like it made you obsessed into
understanding that
other people shouldn't go through what i
went through what what actually happened
what what was it
that that's that said to you this is
just this whole thing is upside down
it was truly a perfect storm where
everything that can go wrong
went wrong and every time one of them
happened
you can write it off and you can say i
have great doctors and they really care
about me and i feel taken care of but as
they add up
you just get more and more frustrated
like the bills don't make any sense to
you
the wait times for appointments don't
make any sense to you you're injured
you're like i have an immediate need to
see a doctor and they're like
you can see the doctor in six to eight
weeks they're like i can't move
i'm 25 i'm 26 like like this is crazy
um and so you i think
really for me what was really profound
was the moment that i realized that they
had all added up
and for me it was like how is it
possible
that one after the next after the next
after the next of these things could
have happened
and does this happen to everyone with a
chronic condition and everyone who's
um who's interacting with the healthcare
system more regularly because
that's crazy right and so
as you even i know i'm trying to put
myself in your shoes and
you're sitting there and you're saying
okay i'm 25. this
this one of the most complicated
bureaucratic
uh you know and financial ecosystems in
the world the u.s healthcare system
is wrong what do you do then
how like what is that you're just so
nice at that point in time you just
think
oh i've worked in e-commerce for a
couple of years so obviously i
understand that
and which of course you don't you've
been a couple of years
and then you think this is a retail
business and it should be an e-commerce
business and so i started obsessing and
the first thing i obsessed over was the
pharmacy and i got so lucky to get
connected
to the founder and ceo of capsule and i
said this is crazy
this is a retail business that should be
an e-commerce business and he said
it's actually a healthcare business and
there's a ton below the surface kind of
like an iceberg
but you can't even see and the reason
that this went wrong are this and the
reasons that that went wrong or that
and they're all deeply entrenched
interest and you have to move
you know stakeholders together you have
to create value for everyone
and i think for me working at capsule
was such an incredible opportunity
because it was really the chance
to learn every different part of the
health care system the pharmacy is this
really amazing touch point that touches
doctors and hospital systems it touches
insurance companies payers
touches pharmacy benefit managers such
as pharmaceutical companies wholesalers
and so you really have and patients
consumers at the end of the day
and so you really have this total look
at what are all the different pieces of
the health care system what are the
motivations the incentives how do we
figure out how to align those for people
and make change
and so an accident followed by a
realization
followed by deep obsession followed by
an introduction deep
obsession deep deep obsession followed
by this you know what it what it sounds
to me like this you know this
wide range of introduction into the
system and how the different incentives
work in the different counterparts
you spend some time as an entrepreneur
in residence and then you narrow down
on a very specific segment of the
healthcare system which i
intuitively might be the biggest one it
is indeed the biggest one yeah
why weight management why yeah
with metabolic health and
so i think for me it was deeply personal
my mom had a doctor's appointment she
learned that she needed to lose weight
to get back in control of her health
and she asked me for help she asked me
to help her find a doctor who could help
her do that
and my gut reaction was are there
doctors who help you do that which is
crazy because we're talking about the
largest category of chronic disease that
we have
ever experienced we were talking about
70 or 75 percent of american adults
we were talking about 88 of american
adults being what the cdc defines as
poor metabolic health
and so um i helped her find this doctor
in new york
and we were both crazy shocked excited
confused to learn that there are doctors
who can help you get control of your
weight and that they do that by helping
you improve your underlying metabolic
health
and so for me the curiosity comes out
the obsession comes out i start reading
all the research i start looking into
the medications and
all of the research on this class of
medications called glp1 medications
shows that the combination of glp ones
and intensive behavior therapy or a form
of cognitive behavioral therapy for
weight loss
is the most effective solution we have
for long-term sustained outcomes
and the most effective solution we've
ever had for long-term sustained
outcomes
and so i started asking the doctors
where do you do this where do you do
this combination and they say
in the real world we just prescribe the
medications and tell you to diet and
exercise
and i'm like but we know that it takes
so much more than that
and they say i know it just it's just
it's unfortunate
we only do that in the clinical research
and so i start writing to the people who
did the clinical research i spent a lot
of time
during the entrepreneur in residence
making building relationships with the
people who have really pioneered obesity
science and nutrition science over the
last
couple of decades and said how would you
bring this clinical research to people
anywhere
everywhere at an affordable price and we
we plotted through what should the
business look like and how we do that
and so when you're sitting at that
inflection point and
what does it feel like because it sounds
to me and i love
the part of that i love moving for the
journey go ahead
i was just gonna say i love i love this
part of the journey too and i tell it to
people all the time and it sounds
super cheesy and i will repeat it for
the hundredth time but
you will have a million ideas you will
think all of these ideas
would be really fun businesses to run
you'll picture yourself running them
you'll think this is definitely the
thing i want to work on for the next 10
or 20 years
and then you will wake up one morning
realizing that like you fell asleep
thinking about one idea you woke up
thinking about one idea you dreamed
about that idea you got in the shower
and you thought about that idea like you
will reach obsession
and that's the thing i think you can
spend 20 years working on
and it feels totally different than all
of the other ideas that you've had where
you're like
yeah this would be a really great
business to build and the world should
should have this business and
it would be really fun to run this
business and i would be uniquely good at
running this business like
none of that's enough you have to wake
up obsessed with the thing
that you want to spend 20 years doing
because everyone tells you this and it
doesn't ever land so i'll just say it
and know that it won't land it's a total
marathon
like there's no sprinting involved
and you have to just be in it and you
have to be committed to it and so
you have to figure out for you what's
going to keep you excited and engaged
for the long term
i have to say that i'm seeing the
obsession you know pour out of you
and you know through your eyes through
your smile through everything
still you have to ground yourself right
and with that obsession you have to
understand okay
game plan how do i actually go about
this how do i channel this obsession
into something that is tangible
something that is meaningful before we
even get to that weight management in
general
paint me a picture you know even with
numbers what what does it even mean why
is this
you know the most important problem to
tackle in the us healthcare system today
there has never been a better time to
understand this if we think about
why was kovid so dangerous in the u.s
why was kovac
so why were the death rates so high in
the us it is uniquely
directly tied to our metabolic health so
metabolic health is defined by the cdc
by five different metrics your waist
circumference so the amount of visceral
or stomach fat that you have
your blood pressure your cholesterol
your hdl cholesterol specifically
your blood sugar and your um
i'll think of the last one in a second
um but the point being i barely remember
my own name when i wake up saying
you know it's really hard to loan a list
um
and the idea is if these five metrics
aren't all in great shape
you're going to be in for metabolic
health and you're going to be at greater
risk of
all sorts of other downstream chronic
disease and if you think about what the
number one source of chronic disease is
it's obesity
and we know fundamentally differently
than we thought about obesity 10 years
ago how we think about obesity today
which is that it is a disease it's
genetic it's hormonal it's biologic
it does all different components it has
lifestyle components but it has
biologic components too and so for me
when i learned that 175 million american
adults were living with overweight and
obesity
i realized like we have to do something
to get help for those people
we have to do something to get help but
we know how to fix this
we've been doing it in clinical research
for two decades and we haven't been
getting it to people
and how do we get it to people right and
so
when you're obviously i'm i'm picking up
here that you're not going to
be you know in the middle of this u.s
healthcare system with
with what you're describing is upside
down incentives you're thinking of a
different approach
to to tackle the most imp important
problem
how does that how does that work and
calibrate what does that actually work
with
the fifth is your blood fats your
triglycerides
just case anyone was still listening
remind me your question again
i love it you see i i that's the
obsession that i love
the question is calibrate obviously you
know you're talking on one hand that
this healthcare system in the u.s is
upside down you're talking about
you know regardless it's upside down i
have to solve this because i i can't
live knowing that this is such such a
tragically
operating system how how does calibrate
attempt to solve this
this is why this is such a why now
question and it's such an
interesting one and covet has totally
changed my answer from what it would
have been a year and a half ago
a year and a half ago this was about
doctors know this
pharma companies know this insurance
companies are willing to pay for this
and no one has told consumers about this
i isabelle with a background in
e-commerce
and pharmacy have to be the person to
tell consumers about this
like i i have to build a team and a
product that will get consumers
on board with this and will change
consumer perception about this and so we
set the mission of the business to
change the way the world treats weight
and we meant it twofold we meant first
to change the way that we think about it
the way that we talk about it change the
conversation about it because that's how
you get consumers
in the loop here and you help consumers
understand that there is a solution that
involves
fixing their underlying biology rather
than dieting and exercising all of these
willpower things that don't work long
term for people
and then the second piece of that
mission is to change the standard of
care
and to say what we're doing at calibrate
proves that this works in the real world
and that everyone should be doing it
because that's how you reach 175 million
american adults calibrates not going to
treat all of those people
but doctors primary care doctors should
be treating those people medicare
advantage plans should be treating those
people
employers should be making sure that
people have access to this care and so
over time
it's about taking the business and
making it more available and accessible
to people at every price point
by helping by getting other people to
see the value in what we're doing
right and so today with dozens of people
on board you know as employees within
calibrate
as a leader what how do you get them to
reach
your level of obsession i don't think
any of anybody can but
how how do you how do you encourage the
people working with you
to have that intrinsic motivation that i
can feel coming through the screen right
now
so a year ago we were five people today
we are 105 people
so we've hired a hundred people entirely
remotely through a pandemic
but it is certainly the largest team i
have ever managed
um and it is you know no one gets it
right and i take advice left right and
center it's the only thing i talk to
investors and other founders about like
how do you get the team right what did
you do wrong with the team what did you
do right with the team what do you wish
you knew earlier about the team
i think for me it's really about how do
you align what you want to deliver to
the customer
with what you want the team to how you
want the team to operate
and for me that's about having two
values one is we're going to drive real
results
for our customers we're promising total
change a total total reset of metabolic
health for customers
so we are screening for people who are
really really good at driving outcomes
and results very motivated by that
the second is we call it in it together
but what we mean there is
people have been on weight loss journeys
their entire lives and they feel really
alone
and so how do we make them feel like a
team of people is there to support them
we build an amazing team who are really
good at working together and enabling
and empowering each other to do their
best work
and so for us when we find people who
are both of those things
it always works and we find people who
are one of those things
it never works wow i love that
isabel i know how terribly busy you are
i really appreciate you taking the time
to be here and and i have to let you go
soon but i have three
short and fun questions for you so we'll
just power through those quickly
what is that your favorite subject in
middle school or high school
oh my goodness um so i switched
i switched middle schools in the middle
of middle school and i hadn't taken
a language and so they didn't really
know what to do with me and so they put
me in a couple of other people who had
both had all joined in the middle of
middle school
into a latin class with a teacher who
happened to know a little bit of latin
i just fell in love with it i ended up
taking latin all through uh middle
school and high school
because it's kind of like this
combination of math puzzle
and also a little bit of linguistics but
um
it ended up being probably my favorite
overall i love it
one of your role models somebody that
inspires you my mom
100 all day every day and
three words that you would use to
describe isabelle canyon
so we built the calibrate brand around
three words
warm caring and authoritative and i
would say
that those three things are hard to get
into one person or one or one brand or
one persona
and i think that for me they really
encompass
the first three things you would think
about me and hopefully that manifests
his passion the way that you saw today
um but um i think those three isabelle
thank you so so much yeah i really
appreciate it thank you michael really
really positive impact and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you very very much
thank you
[Music]
you